you guys smacks we just got in the new
Galaxy Tab s6 light and today we're not
only going to open it up and give you
give you guys our impressions we're also
gonna be comparing it to Apple's 10.2
inch iPad that is incredibly popular
we're gonna see which one is the better
buy for you now when I first heard that
Samsung is releasing this s6 life I
thought it was gonna be a replacement to
the s5 II but it doesn't really seem so
there are a lot of differences some
things that are just very interesting
that we're gonna be talking about in as
far as this comparison we're gonna look
at the displays the speakers performance
how the pen support works and much more
so we have our S Pen in here let's get
that out and the charger interestingly
this is about a 7 point 5 watt charger
compared to 12 watts on the iPad I
wonder why they didn't put a 15 watt
charger like they do on their higher-end
models so maybe just you know going for
budget and let's get this s-pen out
feels fairly light it's flat on one side
I'm guessing it's probably magnetic try
it out yep there you go
that is nice if you're going to be using
it you could just click it down if you
want to do a couple things with your
hands without having to set it down of
course the Apple pencil is not included
with the iPad and it will not do that
let's start out with the exterior so you
guys see them on the table right here
the iPad is a fair bit larger and that's
because we have a pretty weird
difference in terms of aspect ratios
which we'll talk about in just a bit but
comparing the exterior the Samsung has a
larger camera bump and actually is a bum
it's much larger overall the module but
if we take a look at the actual camera
lens inside they're about the same size
the iPad does have a microphone back
here which is probably good taking a
look at the bottoms the iPad has the
Lightning jack or lighting port whereas
the s6 light has a USB type-c port which
is great but it's very interesting how
it is offset almost at the back of the
tablet you can see that the s6 only has
one speaker here at the bottom where the
iPad has stereo speakers but if we flip
to the other side
the s6 light has another speaker whereas
the iPad doesn't and we're gonna do
speaker comparisons
soon that means if you're watching
videos you are gonna have stereo sound
which you won't with the iPad now as far
as the thickness they are very close but
you guys might below see that the s6
light does not have a smart connector
for a keyboard so that is very
interesting both of them do have
headphone jacks and once again it's
interesting how the headphone jack on
the s6 light is so close to the edge it
is very interesting and that's actually
because of the display technology which
we'll also talk about in a bit
now the actual keys here are all on one
side and these feels really nice they
don't feel cheap like on a lot of other
tablets and even though the Essex light
is much smaller physically it's only
about 16 grams lighter than the iPad now
let's talk about the smart connector
here for a bit samsung calls there's
their keyboard dock connector and it was
on the s5 II you can buy a keyboard
cover for that tablet but this year
Samsung decided to get rid of that
connector so they are designing this
tablet to be used as a tablet and not as
an all-in-one device with a nice
keyboard whereas Apple is doing the
opposite this year they actually added
their smart connector and they have
multiple options for keyboards including
ones that support trackpad so this is
Logitech's new keyboard case that also
supports the trackpad it uses a smart
connector so you don't have to connect
over bluetooth and we recently reviewed
it and for the money this is a great
laptop replacement where you have a good
keyboard you have trackpad support and
this is just something that you are not
going to be able to achieve with the s6
light I do want to mention a Samsung
does sell a targis keyboard case on
their site it's about a hundred and
fifty bucks and they say that it's sleek
stylish and and whatever but to me it
looks like a thirty dollar keyboard
cover on Amazon I'm sure there's gonna
be third-party accessories for this
device I probably wouldn't buy that
because it just looks thick and really
old and it's using bluetooth for the
back into a price I think it's kind of
crazy now let's go ahead and get this
set up I'm
here on the section where you choose
your recognition the s5e had a
fingerprint scanner on the side the iPad
has apples touch ID right here on the
bottom yours tap it BAM we are logged in
and it's interesting to see that the s6
light actually doesn't offer that at all
you could use spatial recognition which
just uses the camera so it's not that
secure can be fooled by a picture of you
or just use a pin so we do not have a
fingerprint scanner at all and now let's
compare the displays both of these use
LCD displays Samsung is no longer using
that OLED display that they had an s5e
which I absolutely loved now as far as
the sharpness or detail the iPad has 3.5
million pixels Apple calls it their
retina quality display everything looks
nice and sharp and what the Essex like
they actually lowered it from 4 million
pixels last year to 2.4 million pixels
for the s6 light so it's no longer OLED
and the actual sharpness and detail is
quite a bit lower as well now if we're
reading text and stuff like that it
doesn't look too bad at this distance
but they do seem to be some scaling
issues like when I look at this folder
some of the icons I see just a lot of
aliasing and I think that might be
because of the new resolution and the
aspect ratio this is a 5 by 3 aspect
ratio display compared to that our usual
16 by 9 now 16 by 9 is already wider
than the 4 by 3 of the iPad but 5 by 3
is even wider than that so that is a
very interesting choice by Samsung so
that means that even if you're watching
just a 16 by 9 aspect ratio video let's
maximize this you're gonna get black
bars on the top and bottom now it's
better for a widescreen video but for a
lot of things it is an interesting
choice I'll say one benefit though with
this wider screen is that I can't hold
it in just one hand and if you're like
me with larger hands you'll be able to
do that which you can't do that with
iPad one area that the s6 light is
better than the iPad is that it's using
a laminated display so you don't have a
gap between the screen
the touch surface and that does help
with reflectivity so if you guys see
right there the iPad is definitely more
reflective and comparing brightness the
iPad is just slightly brighter but it is
super close that iPad also has better
viewing angles but ultimately if you're
going to be using these in bright rooms
or outdoors you're gonna have an easier
time seeing what's on the screen on the
Samsung s6 light and now let's compare
pen or pencil support for these two
tablets the s6 light comes with this S
Pen it definitely feels very very
lightweight and lighter than the one
with the s6 so it is a more budget
option it does still have a button here
and as soon as you bring it closer it
will actually hover so it is connected
smartly and then you get this little
menu giving you options for things you
could do with the s-pen so I'm gonna go
ahead and launch that and as far as the
iPad we have the Apple pencil this thing
is not included it costs $100 it is
pricey but it feels like it's about four
times the weight of the s-pen it
definitely feels higher quality we don't
have any sorts of buttons but let's
compare how they draw the iPad does a
surprisingly good job for a budget
inexpensive iPad there is a very little
lag even though it's not as good as the
iPad a lot of people use these and as
far as pressure sensitivity it is
actually really good as well so if I am
just barely touching this display it's
thin I push down it's much thicker and
then I could just mix that up you guys
see how responsive that is and then now
let's go ahead and go to the s-pen and
do you guys hear that we have a little
drawing sound it's very interesting so
this is also touch sensitive pressure
sensitive so if I press harder it's
thicker if I let go it's thinner not as
big of a difference though and then
can you guys see that lag it's actually
worse than I expected and it's also kind
of inconsistent if you guys could see
that sometimes it like catches up with
the delay and it's almost like there's
just frames that are missing or
something overall I would say if you're
gonna be somebody that you know wants to
do a lot of drawing and writing I would
definitely push you towards the iPad
just because not only does it have a lot
less delay it's better sensitivity you
guys could see that right there you have
a huge amount of apps on the app store
that are designed for iPad a massive
selection and that is really nice if
you're gonna be serious with the S Pen
or the pencil and now let's compare the
speakers you guys put on your best pair
of headphones and let's take a listen
[Music]
and there you guys have it you let me
know your thoughts down in the comment
section below
obviously we're listening through
microphone through YouTube so I'll give
you guys my opinion and I just have to
say wow what a difference having those
stairs speakers being not only on the
bottom but just having one on the side
makes a big difference for just whole
immersion when you're holding or Rosanna
Lee but not only that the volume of the
speaker's themselves it's a lot louder
it actually the quality of the sound
coming out is better as well so I know
that Samsung got rid of the two speakers
it used to be a quad speaker system in
the s5e I don't know how much of a
difference that made because it still
sounds fantastic and the iPad is much
worse now on top of the speaker
difference we also have a difference in
the aspect ratios we talked about before
with this five by three aspect ratio
instead of sixteen by nine we do have a
few black bars here added for sixteen by
nine content but on the iPad you see
that these bars are pretty massive and
if you're gonna be watching movie Slee
on Netflix the black bars get even
bigger on both and at some points the
black bars look like they're almost the
same size as what you're watching with a
twenty one by nine video on the iPad so
the screen aspect ratios along with the
differences in speakers and having those
theories speakers be on each side with a
Samsung if you're mainly wanting the
device for watching movies are gonna do
a lot of that the Samsung is definitely
a better option now one interesting
thing to note though is in the YouTube
app I'm leasing 1080p60 on the Samsung
usually gives you high resolutions
whereas iPads they're limited to 1080p
60 and that could be because of the
processor that is inside of this Samsung
so let's go ahead and get into
performance
I have Geekbench five opened up right
here I'm gonna go ahead and run the CPU
benchmark
now last year Samsung was using a 670
Snapdragon processor and that was the
biggest limitation I really like this 5e
on everything but the performance this
year they actually switch to one of
their own processors the 9610 let's see
what it gets and the iPad is still using
the
8nm fusion processor as it did last year
and that one is about four years old now
what a big difference now as far as the
multi-core is only about 10-15 percent
difference with the s6 light being
slower but as far as a single core we
have 346 compared to 768 and the 810
fusion is a 4-year old processor now and
it looks like the essex light is
actually slightly slower than the s5 II
from a year ago and that is a major
disappointment to me because I was my
biggest complaint was the performance it
was kind of sluggish and it wouldn't be
future-proof if you buy that device so
that is definitely a bummer so it looks
like when Samsung switched to their own
processor is probably a cost-saving
measure not to try to get better
performance for the money and now let's
compare the graphics performance
I ran Geekbench 5's compute test and our
budget cheapest iPad basically has
double the graphics performance compared
to the s6 light that is a massive
difference when you know we're talking
about these tablets having such close
price points so another kind of
disappointment performance wise and
let's go ahead and finish off comparing
the cameras here is a shot with the both
of the rear cameras they are both 8
megapixel and then here is a shot with
the front facing camera the iPad uses a
1.2 megapixel compared to a 5 megapixel
on the s6 light and here's the
comparison of the front-facing camera
for video and the microphone right now
this is the s6 light and then this is
the 10.2 inch iPad as far as the quality
you guys let me know which one looks
better and which one sounds better down
in the comment section below and here
once again
Samsung lower the quality of the cameras
compared to last year's s5e it went I
think from a 12 megapixel down to an
eight megapixel it does still look
better than the iPad at least a front
facing camera which that is good and
let's go ahead and just talk about
prices the
comes in at $329 but there are tons of
sales I'll remind you guys we have links
in the video descriptions and you can
get it as low as $250 at times I spent
280 for this one whereas the s6 light it
is $350 now that does include the s-pen
which Apple does not include there's but
if you score it for you know 250 280 you
add in the pencil the prices are fairly
similar which one do I suggest for most
people well I think most people are
gonna be happier with the iPad I think
there's a massive difference in quality
for the pen support that's the main
thing that seems like added this year
and we have that now but the pen quality
is not great and there are a lot of
downsides to this s6 light for example
they removed a keyboard dock connector
the cameras got worse the display is no
longer OLED is lower of resolution the
performance didn't get better so a lot
of things that I complained about
they're not better whereas the iPad it's
not a great device like the iron iPads
but for that price point it packs in a
ton and a lot of people a lot of Android
guys will actually buy iPads just
because of the App Store there's a huge
amount of optimized apps the pen support
is great and not what that's what makes
this a great value and on top of that we
have the smart connector this year which
Apple added and we can connect keyboards
like this Logitech with the trackpad
which makes it a nice budget laptop
alternative or Chromebook alternative
and Samsung got rid of that this year so
honestly if you're thinking about buying
the s6 light I would go as far as saying
go by the s5 II instead as you guys saw
there are a lot of features and the
Samsung is scrapped just to be able to
drop the price point by $50 and include
the s-pen which is a pretty cheap pen
and it's not even that great so if you
want the Android tablet for watching
movies get the s5 e the display is
better it's OLED as quad speakers and a
lot of other benefits including keyboard
support I think that is the better
option for you guys will leave a link
down below
well what I'd like to know your thoughts
as well in the comments section which
one do you think is the better
bye thank you guys for watching you
click that circle above to subscribe and
if you want to see a couple great videos
maybe the review of this keyboard case
for the iPad we will have that or right
over there
this has been max and we'll see you in
the next video
[Music]